hello everybody so I just want you all
to know in case you haven't heard the
news Google Plus has merged with YouTube
so if you're trying to leave a comment
right now and you can't it's probably
because you have it linked up your
Google+ account to your YouTube account
thus causing chaos
I feel like Google+ is trying to be a
really super sophisticated Tumblr I use
the way I tend to think about it is if
Twitter we're just saying hey guys I see
you having fun I'm gonna let you finish
but if you'd like to send another tweet
you're gonna have to log into Pinterest
and now send your tweets through
Pinterest instead a little something
like that
I've actually been testing it out for a
while so to me nothing has changed at
all but for a lot of you guys it's been
pretty much the most tragic thing they
could potentially have ever happened in
your life thus far if that's the case
don't worry
okay so there's gonna be a lot more
disappointment coming up in your life I
promise you this is just a great little
preparation for your future not to be
negative or anything but I've actually
spent pretty much my entire online
existence of not really having an
opinion about anything and it served me
pretty well I don't really like
confrontation also pretty much I've wet
in my entire life trying to avoid it as
much as possible which leave each of the
whole Google+ thing I wasn't even gonna
make a video about it but everyone he's
asking what I think and I'm gonna be
completely honest with you I don't
actually care at all first of all don't
be confused because that doesn't mean
that I don't care about you guys
watching this video because I do and
that is one thing that I actually really
do care about more than anything that's
what's made YouTube YouTube so until I
can't actually post a video on YouTube
anymore even though most of you guys
can't actually even find the videos that
I post on YouTube even if you are
subscribed these things are all out of
our control there's no point in us even
caring or worrying or getting upset
about it because there's been so many
petitions out there for YouTube to
change the layout back to how it used to
be change this change that you guys need
to realize YouTube is a part of Google
Google has so many other things going on
that YouTube is just one small little
part so in essence it doesn't really
matter that much which leads me to
another point if I were to stop making
videos if your favorite youtubers were
to stop making YouTube
use tomorrow guess what really doesn't
matter I'm sure you'd miss us I'm sure
you'd wish that we would make videos but
the grand scheme of things doesn't
matter
it's kind of like a super long term
relationship some of you may have been
and some that I have been in where
you've been with a person for so long
years you think about this person every
day you talk to them every single day
then you break up guess what you
probably don't think about that person
at all unless they pop up on your
Facebook feed and you're like hey
remember when we spend so much time
together you move on if you can still
leave a comment great but I think the
one thing that is most upsetting and
what I hate is I hate being told what I
have to do if I want to use YouTube and
if I want to comment and I want to
interact guess what I'm gonna have to do
I'm going to have to freaking sign up
with Google freaking plus and freaking
put my name in first in my last name
which brings us on to a whole nother
point of all of this craziness yes I'm
sure it is a grand scheme for Google to
basically know our first or last name
know everything about us know what we
start to know we do know we eat know we
talk about the problem is YouTube is
such a massive website to make this kind
of change to get everyone to switch over
it's kind of crazy I know the first
couple of days of this whole switch
nothing was working people weren't able
to comment things weren't working you
weren't able to respond to old comments
things just weren't as it should the
only plus side to all of this a plus
side now as a creator we actually have
the choice if I don't want you to say on
my channel guess what you're not gonna
say if I don't want you to say on my
channel guess what you're not gonna say
it kind of crazy that it's taken this
long for that to be able to happen the
comment moderation is so important I
have tried so hard to keep my videos
clean and family-friendly but then you
read in the comments and it's a disaster
it's a mess it's disgusting it's evil no
it doesn't mean that negative comments
are gonna happen that's fine
totally fine just say them in a way
where you don't say it also is a crater
if I want to have somebody be able to
log in to my youtube channel you you
can't really do that without giving them
your actual password well you're gonna
have managers so you can add a manager
on to your Google+ profile and then they
can in return manage your YouTube
channel there are times that I want my
sister to log in and help me with
annotations or do something silly she
can not do that without having my
password also long overdue
fans I was able to add a bunch of you
guys who interact and like and comment
with a bunch of my videos to a top fan
circles so now I can see who has been
amazing people all along and I can put
them in a circle and see what they're
doing still think the circle thing is
kind of strange but whatever threaded
comments you can add some links in
comments now also a hole over to I don't
know guys I just don't think that this
is something that's really worth being
upset over we either deal with every go
find another place to upload our videos
I don't know I don't know what to say
I think it does matter as the community
and that's you guys you are still able
to comment you are still able to
interact and if you haven't yet linked
your Google+ profile just be careful
because if you want to keep your YouTube
channel name does give you that option
so just to be very careful when you're
clicking it'll say change to real name
or it'll say keep YouTube channel name
so make sure you click that cuz I made
that mistake and totally screwed up
everything but that's the hard part it's
such a massive company it's such a huge
change things are bound to happen like
I've accidentally signed up and I have
like five Google+ profiles under one
account I don't know how that's even
possible but my sister did the same
thing so there's so much confusion
there's just so many people involved in
so many of these things which is why it
makes it so insignificant to I mean it
may be the biggest deal to all of us but
the actual Google like it's like
whatever well I'm gonna go I would love
to hear you guys feedback you're honest
100% honest feedback don't just hate for
the sake of hating I mean is I've
already told you I don't care like I
don't like it I don't hate it I just
don't care I can still comment I could
still interact I'm not a troll going by
some secret crazy fake name that I need
to just hide behind I think that's one
of the things that has made the internet
amazing as you can be anonymous you can
be someone else and I think that's one
of the things that a lot of people have
loved about YouTube is you can be
someone else I'm gonna shut up because
I'm sure all of you hate me so even if
you do guess what you can't say you
can't say I hate you because I blocked
that word by